oh my
gosh I know it looks so good have yall
ever met we not no we haven't what an
honor I'm like Jesus just bringing
people together okay so so I have to ask
you this is the craziest story to me so
you from Atlanta I am born and raised
uhhuh and then you're in a where where
does the jump for to go to Korean
competition show where what happened
there it's this is a story okay okay so
go to school okay graduate get a job at
Delo Consulting doing strategy asked for
a year off and I went to India to do
service work essentially and while I was
there I got a email through a YouTube
video that a TV show had watched and I
thought it was a scam and it said like
hey come to Korea send us your passport
what happens when you do that you
identity send us your passport yes and I
was like this is going to this is a
shady um but I was like I've always
wanted to do a music thing why not just
send just enough information to see if
they send me a flight and sure enough
they did so I get to Korea a few days
later yeah uh started an audition
program very much like the one you were
on yeah um and then I got to the top
five signed a record deal quit my job
and uh started my career in music yeah
that what a story to grow up in Atlanta
and I I just thought that was a crazy
jump so what I hear they have a nickname
for you in Korea I love this nickname
did you love it uh it
it was uh is it the nation's boyfriend
yeah I was like do I say this myself
nation's it's I think it's is it the N
the nation's boyfriend yeah I was called
the nation's boyfriend that's just like
everyone's boyfriend I'm
just the nation's boyfriend what does
this mean so have you asked I was told
well so pretty much in Korea there's a
phrase
called yeah so that means one Eric Nom
per household so it's like it's it's
like actually kind of in like like the
dictionaries and like if you search it
it's like a thing you're like Beyonce
with bootylicious you just like made a
word like that's incredible but here's
the thing I didn't make it I don't know
who made it but it was made and then all
of a sudden I was on this uh this fun
reality show it was you know reality
where I'm fake married for like nine
months and through that and through
being on all these I know I know I know
did like being married how did you like
being married it was great doesn't stick
for
everyone mine was like 9 months okay you
know again it was it was yeah in reality
also true um but it was fun but it was
through doing a lot of shows and I was
on any sort of TV show radio show
anything everywhere and I think people
just really saw me everywhere and I
think people liked me in general and so
I got very likable thank you so yes you
are very likable so much so house on a
hill where did the where did this Al
album title come from I was I was
wanting to buy a house and I was looking
all around I had happened to find this
beautiful house in LA and I was like
this is this is the home and then I was
like wait but I'm never anywhere do I
really need yeah to make this thing and
then I thought of I went down this
Rabbit Hole of thinking about all the
things that we're told we need to be
happy or successful that is getting
property or having a certain family or
looking a certain way or having all
these things you think if I do this I'll
be happy if I have this yeah but then I
start to realize it's like no matter
what you have you're always going to
want the shiniest the newest thing the
upgade and apple gets us every time
every time they get us I don't stand in
line anymore though I'm not standing in
L I'll order it on the yeah wait till
they work out the Kinks no but you're
right though that that is true like
especially when we're younger we think
like oh this will make me happy yeah so
that was kind of the start of the
process which led me down a complete
rapbit hole of a existential crisis of
stores so just figuring out what makes
me happy what makes me tick what makes
me really want to get up every day and
do what I do and that's kind of how we
we built out the album trying to figure
out some of those so that house on the
hill you thought you wanted wasn't
really what you wanted yeah no I think
one day I do but right now I'm good I
think it's enjoying the process of
creating of touring and meeting
incredible people like yourselves yeah
do you have did you have that when you
were younger I I used to do that too
especially because I grew up with no
money then they give you money and
they're like what do I do with this and
and and I would you you totally end up
buying stuff like oh if I had this house
I've gotten Texas if I did this I
definitely went through all of that was
not as smart as you actually bought the
house and and just you know kind of went
through the motions did you do that I
did I did you know because the American
dream says that you're supposed to you
know have a house and 2 three kids and
you know but I and I felt bad about
myself for a long time because I was not
a I'm an artist you know that's hand to
mouth that's check to check so like I
didn't amass enough funds until I was in
my until I was 50 yeah to buy my first
house yeah um yeah you have enough
experience in it I think you probably
made way better decisions than I did
well I don't know about that yeah cuz
I'm not really that great with money so
it is important though because Society
does tell you like what you this is what
you need to be happy this is what you
need and it's everyone's different so I
yeah you're very clever and smart for to
be so young um but we need to do another
commercial break everybody Eric's tour
and album and song are called house on a
hill you can find both
online
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home